good evening good evening I'm so so
thrilled that you all are all here I'd
like to welcome you to the 2017 Henry
Louis Gates Jr annual lecture my name is
Jacqueline gold Lee and I'm professor of
English and African American Studies
here at Yale and I'm also chair of
Yale's African American Studies
department the gates lecture marks the
capstone of African American Studies
academic year not simply because the
event literally closes out our year of
public programming and on that note I
know that this is the last day of
classes and I know that you've summoned
a lot of energy to be here but I think
it will be worth your effort and all of
our time but you made the right choice
to be here today and I thank you for
that but the gates lecture series is a
peak is a particularly occasion for our
department because these talks give us a
chance to think incisively about the
largest issue and most decisive
developments that shape our fields
inquiry this series allows us to open
those discussions as broadly as possible
to include colleagues and students
across Yale's campus and from the New
Haven community so on behalf of a
department I'm thrilled to welcome you
all to join our work here today this
year is particularly special because the
2017 gates lecture marks the fifth year
of the series as you see this series has
brought world leading scholars in black
diaspora studies to Yale the philosopher
Kwame Anthony Appiah the dramatist poet
critic and Nobel laureate Walachia Anka
the legal theorist Patricia Jade
Williams black feminist theorist and
literary clinic critic Hortense pillars
in our distinguished lecturer today
Dorothy Roberts about whom I'll share
more shortly all of these scholars come
to share their newest original work with
us and this way we honor the example of
a scholar after whom the series is named
Henry Louis Gates Jr who's with us here
today
[Music]
professor gates is pioneering literary
criticism theory and archival recovery
projects have been like our lecturers
scholarship foundational for
african-american and black diaspora
studies and indeed for liberal arts
inquiry as such it's exciting for our
department to present the extraordinary
work of our fields pathfinding scholars
to the entire Yale and New Haven
community so again welcome to the work
that we do to organize an event like
this requires a communal effort and I
want to give thanks to the Yale staff
colleagues and units that have made
today possible from the African American
Studies department our excellent staff
Lisa Monroe Jasmine Williams and Edith
Rothkopf have kept this project going
for the last year to make today possible
and I want to thank them for their work
[Music]
I'd also like to thank our colleagues
here at the Whitney Humanity Center who
have hosted us here for this series and
a special thanks to the director Gary
Thomasson for his support thanks Gary
[Music]
[Applause]
and we have a tremendous very special
thanks to Daniel and Joanna Rose who
created the endowment that funds the
gates lecture series mr. Rose is here
with us today as well I thank you for
your support and now to introduce this
year's gates lecturer Dorothy Roberts
comes to us from the University of
Pennsylvania where she holds several
distinguished posts she is a George a
wise University professor of law and
sociology the Raymond pays in Sadie
Tanner Michelle Alexander professor of
civil rights and the professor of
Africana Studies
she's also the founding director of the
program on raised science and society
sponsored by africana studies at Penn
professor Roberts received her JD from
Harvard Law School in 1980 and in a
wonderful fitting coincidence she earned
her BA in anthropology from Yale College
in 1977 so we're glad to welcome you
home
reading professor Robert CV is I must
say an exhilarating and I mean that
exhilarating experience her range of
experience and accomplishments are
astonishing after graduating from
Harvard Law she clerked for the
Honorable Constance Baker motley of the
US District Court for the Southern
District of New York and then practice
law for nearly a decade she has taught
at the nation's leading law schools at
Penn now but also at Rutgers Newark and
northwestern she's also held visiting
professorships at Stanford and Harvard
and she's held major fellowships and
grants from the Fulbright Scholars
program the American Council on learners
societies the Robert Wood Johnson
Foundation and the National Science
Foundation
her most recent Awards and I'm just
naming those from the last two years
otherwise you'd be here old
they included these are meaningful I
mean they're inspiring to me anyway
the 2016 lifetime achievement award for
the Society of family planning she was
elected to the board of directors of the
American Academy of political and social
science and in 2015 she won the Solomon
Carter Fuller award of the American
Psychiatric Association for quote
providing significant benefit to the
quality of life for black people I would
hope that all of our scholarship has
that kind of impact professor Roberts
has offered three books each of which
are landmarks and critical race theory
and legal studies african-american
studies black feminist theory critical
Science and Technology studies and
Public Policy Studies I'm sure you know
these works killing the black body race
reproduction in the meaning of Liberty
from 1997 shattered bonds the color of
child welfare published in 2002 and
fatal invention how science politics and
big business recreate race in the 20th
21st century published in 2011 even more
she's co-ed at nine volumes spanning
from the First Amendment law to the
politics of HIV health management in the
Caribbean she's published 70 articles
and essays and scholarly journals 32
chapters and edited books that
contributes to daily public media forums
like in New York Times TED Talks and
broadcast news interviews now what I
find exhilarating about this body of
work and there's more receive E is 36
pages long
is Professor Roberts who's sustained
commitment to studying the life worlds
and life prospects of working-class and
impoverished black people more precisely
professor Roberts commitment to practice
a black feminist jurisprudence means
that the struggles black women face to
earn a living wage to afford stable life
enhancing housing to call ready access
to robust health care their own to joy
the freedom to recall Tara Hunter's
phrase of reproductive Liberty
safeguarding their bodies from hostile
coercive in positions of the
scientific and cultural technologies
these struggles our paradigmatic of what
citizenship agency equality dignity and
freedom might mean for all of us
moreover the legal structures that
envelop black woman's daily lives are
for professor Roberts challenges to
injustice that the tools of scholarly
analysis can that must be brought to
bear to solve for instance shattered
bonds examines the racial disparities
that organize child welfare policies in
the United States why are black children
over-represented in child welfare
surveillance and punishment programs
from foster care to juvenile detention
what impacts do the removals of black
children from their families exert on
the community at large her latest book
fatal invention scrutinizes our
contemporary fascination with genomic
science and its implications for what
roberts calls the bio politics of race
for instance studying human populations
at the level of the genes seems to do
away with the social construct of race
consider for instance how DNA banking
has rescued black men from false
imprisonment how liberating is that
science though when we think about how
that genetic material was collected
stored and classified in the first place
what kind of surveillance state does
this use of genomic science require and
legitimize roberts explores these tough
questions deploying the tools of
interdisciplinary black feminist
intersectional analysis of skill care
and rigor she moves from scrupulous
detailed ethnographic description to
wide-ranging synthesis of urban history
and cultural history biology and
genetics political theory and philosophy
she does all of this with clarity and
ease read through these lenses
constitutional and case law court
opinions and public policies are reveal
for what they are
ideologies shaped by humans and in
buying history to advance the aims of
power of human groups over one another
but can power be imagined in ways that
repudiate domination each of Roberts's
books
by speculating on that possibility I
refer to her call for a critical
humanism that closes fatal inventions
and to her theory of group identity and
conceptions of justice which closes
shattered bonds when it was first
published in 1997 her first book killing
the blackbody proposed a new approach to
the meaning of Liberty to understand the
aggregations of black woman's
reproductive rights 20 years later what
lessons can that work in its theory of
power teach us let's begin that
discussion so please join me in
welcoming our 2017 gates lecturer
professor Dorothy Roberts
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you for that wonderful
introduction and you really ask the
question I want to ask in my lecture so
that was without answering it that's
always the fear that's the person who
introduces you is going to answer the
question so thank you
I'm so honored so honored to be asked to
give this lecture in the name of Henry
Louis Gates Jr terrific scholar
unparalleled in this country and around
the world it's such such an honor to
give a lecture that was named after you
and so special that it is the 40th
reunion of my class
Yale Believe It or Not graduated in 1977
and skip as we used to call him was
there as a graduate student I believe
well while I was attending Yale as an
undergrad and it was so wonderful when
we were in the Black House that we could
look to someone who had made it past
graduation and was using his degree to
further explore black life in America
and so I don't know if you realize that
but you were a real inspiration to
undergrads who were not quite sure what
we were going to make of ourselves i
Daniel Rose thank you so much for
endowing this lectureship what a great
idea that was and thanks to not just
because of me but also all the when I
saw all the prior like I guess I knew
who they were but seeing them up there
just made this quadruple II an honor to
give this lecture and thanks to African
American Studies for inviting me and
to the humanity center for this
beautiful venue and all the others who
contributed Lisa Monroe as well for
orchestrating everything and others who
contributed I'm very very honored yes
we're going to have a switch of the
PowerPoint slides all right thank you so
I do want to take this opportunity on
the 20th anniversary of killing the
black body to think about the lessons
that it has taught me thinking back over
20 years how I approached the subject
and how my thinking has expanded over
the last 20 years I've done some
speaking about the book that looks at
how many of the policies or all of the
policies that I described and killing
the black body have just intensified and
are now with our new administration
threatened to be intensified beyond what
I could have even imagined when I wrote
killing the black body but what I want
to do today in this lecture is think
about lessons I've learned over the the
last 20 years I began working on the
subject in 1988 when I became a law
professor and I began to notice
newspaper articles about the
prosecutions of women who used drugs
while pregnant and I immediately thought
that these must be prosecutions
primarily of black women because the
descriptions of how degrading and
dehumanizing
the police procedures were and the
prosecutors descriptions of these women
as totally depraved as lacking maternal
instinct as being deserving that of
health care
but of criminal punishment I just had an
idea that these were black women who are
being treated in this way and as I
investigated the prosecution's I
discovered that that was true
and as I investigated the scholarship
that was being written about them I
discovered that and the advocacy around
it
I discovered that most of the focus was
on a maternal-fetal conflict and the
morality of that the constitutionality
of it the politics of it but no
attention paid to the race of the people
the women who were being prosecuted and
the way in which racism shaped the
transformation of a public health
problem into a crime and so I started on
a project to explain how racism had
influenced these prosecutions along with
gender and along with class these of
course were almost all poor women who
are being prosecuted but also to
describe how the intersection of racism
and sexism and capitalism in America
shaped the very meaning of reproductive
freedom and reproductive Liberty and so
I jumped from a project that focused on
this one issue of prosecutions to a
project that looked over the course of
US history into the contemporary times
to explore ways in which racism and
sexism intersected to affect the
regulation of black womens childbearing
and how that regulation affected the
very way we think about an act and
advocate for reproductive freedom in the
United States reflecting on
that book 20 years later writing a
preface for the new edition I felt a
mixture of exasperation and exhilaration
exasperation because the policies I
described prosecuting women for their
conduct during pregnancy welfare
restrictions based on myths about
welfare mothers getting pregnant just to
get a welfare check high-tech
reproduction that benefited primarily
white middle-class couples at the same
time that black woman's childbearing was
being deterred tried to be deterred and
policies like those they were not solved
in fact there were new forms of these
policies states passing laws that made
it easier for to prosecute women for
drug use during pregnancy and other
kinds of conduct during pregnancy
welfare had been abolished there were
new assaults escalation of assaults on
the access to abortion but at the same
time I was exhilarated to think about
the organizing for reproductive justice
that I'd been a part of over those last
20 years so what I want to focus on
today is thinking back what the lessons
were for me and how my thinking had
changed about the regulation of black
woman's childbearing and I want to talk
about how this regulation helped me to
see better the way in which race is
reproduced also how it helped me to see
how unjust institutions are reproduced
and then how it helped me to appreciate
the significance of black womens
organizing for reproductive justice so
those are the three topics I want to
talk about I begin killing the black
body with a chapter on reproduction and
bondage and I focus on how black woman's
reproductive labor was valuable to
slaveholders because they produced
chattel property for their masters and
their masters owned their children from
the moment of conception
this gave masters white slaveholders a
continuing supply of property to be
forced to work for them for their profit
and it also meant that slaveholders
could do with black children whatever
they wanted to because these children
were their property and so they could
take them from their parents without any
entitlement upon the part of their
parents at all they had absolutely no
claim to their children I focused on how
the way in which black fetuses were
treated paralleled claims at that time
that prosecutors were protecting unborn
black children by locking their mothers
up and I pointed out that during the
slavery era one of the ways of punishing
pregnant and slave women was to dig a
trench in the ground and force the
mother to lie over the trench so that
the fetus was protected while the mother
was being beaten on her back and the
idea that you could protect a fetus
while brutalizing the mother is just as
absurd and dehumanizing in the 1990s as
it was in the time of slavery
but since I wrote killing the black body
over the last 20 years as I've explored
more the way in which race is reproduced
I realized that black woman's
reproductive labor treated as the
property of slaveholders said even more
about the way in which race is conceived
of as a biological innate trait that is
naturally produced in the bodies of
women that was something that I didn't
write about 20 years ago that was
something that I realized by doing more
research and investigation into the
history of the very meaning of race
realizing how the biological definition
of race undergirds so many destructive
ideologies and practices in Virginia
1662 white colonists were faced with
this question what is the status of
children born to enslaved African women
but fathered by Englishmen for white men
they were all Englishmen at the time
because the most of them is there was no
United States yet no America they were
Englishmen and what what is their status
that's where they could have been
considered white because their fathers
were white there was no natural answer
to this question had to be invented it
had to be answered in terms of politics
not in terms of nature I think this is
one of this question is one of the best
examples of how we know that Ray
isn't natural you can't tell without
referring to the political answers given
to questions like this and they answered
of course we know that the children have
the status of the mother so they could
be enslaved and so these English fathers
were willing to enslave their own
children in order to promote racism and
they invented a definition of race that
made it seem as if the slave status of
black children was merely reproduced in
their mothers didn't stem from power
unjust power arrangements it was
naturally reproduced by black mothers
that captures so deeply the way in which
race is thought of as natural
reproduction that I think that's how
most people think about race that it
black people produce black people and
white people produce white people and
Asian people reproduce Asian people
that's why we have race it just
naturally occurs right through
reproduction but it also set up a way of
thinking that mothers wombs produce
social disadvantage and that by
controlling the reproduction of
disadvantaged people you can control
social disorder and create social order
now that is a way of thinking that has
continued to shape the most horrifying
policies from the time of slavery to
today but it was the
mented into US law and ways of thinking
about race through these questions about
black woman's reproduction so even more
than I realized when I wrote killing the
black body controlling black woman's
reproduction and painting it as the
production of social disadvantage is an
extremely powerful I'm almost ready to
say the most powerful way that people in
power in the United States have thought
about ways of maintaining their power
Virginia then centuries later continues
this merger of biological explanations
for social inequality and maintaining
white racial purity these two laws were
passed on the exact same day in March
1924 in Virginia the one on the left is
the law that allowed for mandatory
sterilization of people deemed to be
genetically or inherently inferior and
the one on the right is the law and by
the way the one on the left is the law
that was upheld in buck vs. Bell by
justice Oliver Wendell Holmes and the
one on the right is the law that was
struck down by the US Supreme Court and
loving versus Virginia but white people
in power in Virginia in the continuation
of the legacy from the 1600s continue to
see the connection between eugenicist
ideology and white supremacist
ideology and that way of thinking
supported the mass sterilizations of
black women who relied on welfare with
youbut eugenicist not only a genesis
ideology promoting that but actual
eugenics boards
continuing into the 1970s at that point
coercing the sterilization primarily of
black women who received welfare on
grounds that these brutal surgeries were
saving the state of north carolina
taxpayer money that would be spent on
these burdens to society and this way of
thinking of black women's rooms as
biological threats to society that you
know producing threatening children
threatening burdens on society that must
be contained that way of thinking
continued in even liberal thinking about
how to solve the problem of black
poverty with the editor editors of the
philadelphia inquirer
in philadelphia the main newspaper in
philadelphia suggesting that the way to
end black poverty is by somehow getting
black women and some people suggest this
should be coerced on black women to use
nor plant a very highly effective form
of contraception long-acting form of
contraception in order to keep the women
who were having too many children from
having them because poverty of course
according to this ideology is caused by
the
reproduction of black women now the
other side
right-wing anti-abortion campaigners
also use the same message to support
their campaign so this is a billboard
that went up this particular one in Soho
in 2011 on the side of a giant building
that displayed the message the most
dangerous place for an african-american
is in the womb same message of black
woman's wounds being threats to their
children and threats to society but in
this case deployed by a group that
wanted to stop access to abortion and
they argued that Planned Parenthood was
a conspiracy to kill off the black race
and that black women either have been
tricked or were in cahoots with Planned
Parenthood to commit genocide against
their own communities
of course these anti-abortion activists
were distorting the history of
sterilization abuse of black women in
order to promote another form of control
over black women's bodies in this case
blaming black women for seeking
abortions and for committing genocide
I also thought more about after writing
killings of black bodies away in rich
which wrought white race is constructed
in the very same debates that I had
written about as constructing black race
the heroin epidemic which is primarily
affecting white people in America has
been portrayed in exactly the opposite
way as the crack epidemic that motivated
my first research and so instead of
newspapers and this is actually a local
Fox stations report instead of them
writing articles about how the mothers
who use drugs while pregnant are
monsters and that their children are the
equivalent of what was called then crack
babies who were predicted not only to
suffer from medical problems but to lack
a social consciousness these were the
kinds of terms used at the time that
they were inevitably going to become
drug addicts and welfare dependence and
criminals unable to learn threats to
society that was part of the media hype
supported by some biomedical researchers
all now disproven as bad research bad
science but that was what helped to
justify the prosecutions of black women
they being now blamed for the impact of
structural inequality on their babies
now under this new epidemic it's
described as
victimizing white communities and
families most of the reporting is very
sympathetic toward pregnant women who
are white women who are addicted to
drugs and it's a problem that our
government needs to solve in some much
more benign and helpful way in fact some
people who are advocating for an end to
the war on drugs which seems so much
more likely now that it's white people
who are being affected and again this is
just how it's portrayed it's not as if
white people didn't use drugs before and
only black people did in the past but
the way it's being portrayed that it's
helpful to tell stories about pregnant
white women or white mothers who are
affected by opioid or heroin use whereas
in the 1980s and 90s I was told when I
tried to advocate on behalf of black
women who were pregnant and had a
substance abuse problem that they they
were bad representations of for the
fight against the war on drugs because
they were so unsympathetic who would
support who would find empathy or
sympathy for a black mother who smoked
crack cocaine during pregnancy so
exactly the opposite way in which these
images are being deployed now it turns
out that it's not just that this
epidemic is being portrayed more
sympathetically once it has become a
problem a white problem but that the
very way in which the epidemic occurred
results from the racialization of drug
addiction
and so many people believe more research
has to be done but many people are
convinced that the reason why we're
witnessing this epidemic now is because
of over prescriptions of opioid
painkillers to white patients who then
became addicted either to the opioid or
to heroin now why is it that this
epidemic is occurring so much more
virulent Lee among white people
why did doctors prescribe so much opioid
painkillers to whites why didn't they
prescribe as a black people well we also
know that there's a long history of
under treatment of black patients for
pain a recent study even showed that
black children suffering in pain from
appendicitis are a third as likely in
emergency rooms to get needed opioid
treatment as white children so the very
racialization of pain and then the
stereotypes that black people are
innately prone to drug addiction and
white people are immune from prag
addiction are the origins of the
epidemic that then is racialized again
and so every aspect of this is
racialized but what my point here is
that while I wrote about how the
racialization of drug use during
pregnancy in the late 80s early 1990s
led to the dehumanizing prosecutions of
black women and the associating drug use
during pregnancy with black people and a
black biothreat
it's also the case that whites were
racialized and the drugs were racialized
as white certain drugs racialized as
white it
works in terms of not just vilifying
blacks but also changing the very way we
think about certain types of addictions
if they can be associated with white
people I contrasted the all of these
policies that sought to reduce the
fertility of black women with the
multi-billion dollar fertility industry
that was geared toward increasing the
numbers of white babies and giving white
people their desire to have children the
images almost always showed white
children being produced by these
technologies and I pointed out that all
the negative images or anytime a black
baby was mentioned in connection with
stories about high-tech fertility were
mishaps the where white women were given
the black man's sperm or inseminated or
their embryos were fertilize their eggs
were fertilized by a black man sperm by
mistake and the children were considered
damaged goods because they weren't white
that racialization of the products of
high-tech reproduction has now been
transferred to the debate around gene
editing with the very similar images
being presented of the perfect baby that
can be produced by gene editing but what
I realized in the last twenty years that
I didn't when I wrote killing the black
body is that this
push to produce perfect babies using
technology in order to avoid the harms
of social disadvantage produce of view
of the bio citizen that relies on
technology rather than on democratic
social change in order to address social
disadvantages and women of all races are
enlisted into this project to use
technologies in order to have better
babies and I don't know that black women
will be excluded from this project of
using technology to have better babies
because black women have been seen as
appropriate objects of regulation and
using genetic selection technologies to
improve their babies may be just as
likely as requiring white women and
other women to use these technologies I
thought that we really are in a period
of a new reproductive dystopia where
it's not just disadvantaged women as in
The Handmaid's Tale who whose wounds are
used to produce babies for other people
but all women might be required have a
duty to use technologies to avoid the
harms of social inequality
another realization that I've had over
the last 20 years is the way in which
the regulation of black woman's
childbearing is not only relevant to the
meaning of reproductive freedom but it's
also relevant to the maintenance of
unjust institutions I really focused on
systems of reproductive regulation as
isolated I think too isolated from other
systems of regulation where black women
are the chief or disproportionately
involved but ideas about their
reproduction and how they supposedly
reproduce threats to society are
critical to maintaining the prison
system the welfare system the foster
care system and I could go on with other
systems education system health care
system but I've in the left 20 years
focused more on these three types of
institutions and the way in which they
intersect with each other and black
women are at the center of all of them
and ideas about the need to urgently
control black woman's childbearing help
to perpetuate the most inhumane aspects
of these systems so I'll mention some
ways in which I've seen them as
connected right at the end of the time I
was writing killing the black body
President Clinton signed two laws and
they're not always connected but they
actually intersect in important ways one
of course was the personal
responsibility and work opportunity
reconciliation Act which welfare
restructuring which abolished the
entitlement of welfare
the other was the adoption Safe Families
Act just a year later which allows
states to speed up the termination of
parental rights and encourage states to
place children in foster care whose
parents rights have been terminated in
to adoption they gave what some of us
called bounties to States to get more
children adopted without providing
similar rewards for returning children
from foster care reuniting them with
their parents or avoiding placement in
foster care in the first place and this
marked the first time in US history that
states were mandated to protect children
from maltreatment and this is mostly
poor children who are served by the
child welfare system but did not mandate
States to provide any kind of support
for families that had never existed
before and so this was an example of
relying on adoption as a way of caring
for children whose parents were
struggling to take care of them states
around the country passed what are
called family caps of child exclusion
policies to try to deter women already
receiving welfare from having more
children if the other ways of modifying
their behavior through the child welfare
system didn't work then the government
had a policy to deter them from having
children at all I ended up as I worked
on these connections writing a book
about the racial politics of the child
welfare system seeing how the
prosecution's of women for drug use
during pregnancy was related to the
removal of their children on math many
more women affected by policies of child
removal than prosecutions
and I saw how the criminal justice
system continued to treat the health
problems of black women now more and
more women white women Asian women
you've some of you know the cases Purvi
Patel in Indiana for example women who
are being prosecuted for still births
and miscarriages laws being passed to
enable prosecutors to punish women for
under so-called fetal protection laws
and then even more broadly the
skyrocketing of the prison population
and it's connection to the these notions
of black women as being bio threats to
society in prison
women shackled incarcerated women
shackled throughout labor and delivery
new forms of dehumanization of
motherhood within prisons and a
continuation of sterilization abuse
moving from eugenics boards into prisons
where we've discovered recently that the
state of California had a program of
sterilizing incarcerated women sometimes
not just against their will but even
without their knowledge and the doctor
in charged justifying it as saving
California taxpayers money because they
didn't have to pay for welfare for these
unwanted children and see these the
intersections of these systems of
welfare prison child welfare operating
together with black women
disproportionately punished and
regulated under
all of these systems and producing
peculiar forms of punishment black women
losing their children disproportionately
to foster care because they have been
incarcerated and all of these systems
fueled by myths about black women sexual
depravity and their need to be
supervised if they're going to care for
children they must be supervised so the
Jezebel represents the uncontrollable
black woman who is innately sexually
life census and therefore an inherently
a bad mother the mammy the asexual black
woman who is safe to care for white
people's children but those are
stereotypes still circulating but the
one that has really done the work of
maintaining these systems of oppression
prison foster care and welfare is sort
of a combination of the two the black
welfare queen who is sexually
licentiousness
but she doesn't care for her children
she gets pregnant in order to get a
welfare check and then spends all the
money on herself doesn't spend it on her
children and this is the dangerous black
woman who is reproducing threats to
society that need to be contained
contained by welfare modification
contained by the foster care system by
removing children and putting them under
the state's custody and by prisons that
circulate people in and out of the
carceral state
now I concluded killing the black body
with what I called a radical vision of
reproductive justice and I called on
theorists to explore how social justice
could be made central to their
conception of rights of harms and of the
value of procreation I didn't know when
I wrote that that it was at the
beginning of an exciting movement led by
women of color to promote a new vision
of the very meaning of reproductive
freedom so these women of color
reproductive justice advocates had
criticized the main framework used to
promote reproductive rights the
framework of choice that reproductive
rights were a way of protecting the
choices of individual women liberty was
about individual choice and it was
mostly about what under this framework
whether or not you could make the choice
to terminate a pregnancy but black women
working in reproductive rights and other
movements recognized that that was
useless
completely useless to women who didn't
have the resources to implement the
choices they made and who were innately
seen as innately unable to make good
choices so it was it just served no
purpose whatsoever other than to blame
women if they couldn't succeed for
making bad choices if anything it was a
harmful way a free
reproductive freedom and so based on a
long history long history of
intersectional analysis this is a quote
and photo of the Combahee River
collective which issued its statement in
1977 calling for commitment to undoing
the major systems of oppression which
they recognized were interlocking based
on that way of understanding how
oppression works women of color like the
Combahee River collective not only
called on us to recognize that our
identities were located within
interlocking systems of oppression but
also called on us to work to ending them
in other words this way of thinking
wasn't just an intellectual project it
was a method of understanding the world
in order to organize to end the
injustice and their intersectional
analysis could be used as a way of
organizing as well it was only by
participating in organizing by primarily
black women but also other women of
color organizations that's me by the way
holding the sign and the March in 2004
with members of the black women's health
imperative that I realized that what I
wrote about as really a theoretical in
killing the black body could be a method
for organizing to actually change the
world
and I have I've been so inspired over
the last 20 years by the act
and organizing of women of color based
on a reproductive justice framework
which I now understand isn't a framework
just for organizing around reproduction
it's a framework for recognizing that
these systems and institutions are
interlocking but that we need to
collaborate and coordinate around
various movements movements to abolish
prisons movements for environmental
justice movements for disability rights
and justice movements for universal
health care all of those are essential
for reproductive freedom but they also
by recognizing how they're essential for
reproductive freedom can lead us to see
how they need to be organized in
coordination with each other in order to
produce social change one of the
successful projects of black womens
organizing for reproductive justice was
putting up billboards in Memphis to
counter the billboards that said black
woman's rooms are the most dangerous
place for African Americans but with a
trust black women campaign that said no
don't stop disparaging black women
making the wrong choices
let's trust black women for making
decisions for themselves their children
and their communities in conclusion I've
also over the last 20 years reflected
more on how intransigent and resilient
so many of these ideologies
talked about are including the
biological concept of race that question
that the colonists in Virginia asked in
1662 is still being answered the same
way by many people including scientists
with the most advanced degrees at the
fanciest institutions in this country
and I've been searching for how do we
break through these barriers of thinking
that are so deeply embedded in every
aspect of us society in these
institutions that seem to give credence
to the biological concepts of race if
you've already got that framework in
your head that the reason for social
inequality is biological difference when
you see social inequality it's evidence
of biological difference it's very hard
very hard to break through that how do
we do it
despite the victories the excitement the
exhilaration the hope of organizing
around reproductive justice I've
struggled over with others what what do
we need to finally do away with these
very basic concepts about humanity these
foundational ideas about human
difference and commonality and I've been
drawn more and more I told the students
I was Carroll waiting what is the court
I said I've got a quote science fiction
because that's I have been drawn more
and more to science fiction and the
quote that I promised you that I find so
so
inspiring as a guide a way of sticking
to it even when it seems as if there's
just a relentless assault on everything
you're trying to do is there's nothing
new Under the Sun but there are new suns
yes
these concepts that came out of slavery
have been replicated reproduced over and
over and over and over and over and over
and over again seems as if we can't get
out of them there there's nothing new
Under the Sun but I have hope and belief
that we can imagine new Suns a new way
of thinking about our relationship with
each other our common humanity and our
differences in the ways that aren't
dehumanizing and it's by studying the
relentless struggle of black women to
resist like that poster there is trust
black women the centuries of devaluation
and stigmatization and dehumanization
that gives me confidence confidence that
we can imagine new suns
so I will end with that and I'm really
anxious to hear your comments and
questions thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you very much for the address
uncle every a little bit more about the
politics of the high-tech reproduction
and the way in which the marketing
around that work always seems to
privilege certain people over others
yeah well you know as I mentioned when I
was working on the book all the images I
could find of high-tech reproductions
these are mostly advertisements by
fertility clinics pictured baby white
babies even newspaper articles about
high-tech reproduction if you look at
the images they are almost always I I
say almost those I actually can't think
of any examples where they worked but I
they're probably maybe some out there of
white babies and lots of white babies is
one fertility clinic that has this dream
of lots and lots of white babies just
going to success stories I may just go
on and on and on and on and on and also
they tend to emphasize what are
stereotypically white characteristics
blonde hair and blue eyes and these
babies and so until pretty recently the
market for high-tech reproductions
seemed to be exclusively white now that
doesn't mean I'm not saying that people
of color didn't participate in it this
is what I'm talking about is what's
advertised so what's what promotes the
industry and what promotes it our images
of white people
however a on Craigslist and other ways
of soliciting egg donors there has been
more diversity in say the last decade
with companies soliciting eggs from
particular racial or ethnic groups and
so you'll find ads that say all
I think I'm quoting all ethnicities
wanted we're especially interested in
Asian eggs I smell this oh but but the
thing is that it so it's very much
racialized it's not as if we're getting
away from race at all it's extremely
racialized and so but there's more
mention of people other than white
people using these technologies in the
last decade or so now shifting to gene
editing which the technology already
exists there are serious debates about
using gene editing for Reproductive
purposes not just to correct a
particular genetic anomaly in one
individual but to change the genetic
structure you know genes that will be
inherited by future generations and as I
pointed out those images you know you
can just google gene editing and go let
go and you'll see I have yet to see a
picture of a black person and what is
supposed to be the glorious future of
gene editing again white images but let
me say more about what I was saying
about a new reproductive dystopia which
is that it's important to recognize
though that gene editing and
reproduction for purposes of genetic
selection as opposed to I mean
technologies for the reproduction
technologies for the purpose of genetic
selection are different from
technologies for the purpose of
enhancing reproduction in other words in
vitro fertilization by itself for
example is for the purpose of producing
a child but gene editing and whether
gene editing and genetic selection which
can all all is already done in embryos
for example to
a with IVF in vitro fertilization that
is for the purpose of selecting out
children that is for the purpose of
so-called perfecting a child who is
going to be born it's it's not for the
purpose of increasing procreation and I
think we have to make a distinction
between technologies for the purpose of
producing more babies and technologies
for the purpose of producing perfect
babies and there is no reason why in the
future all women regardless of race
maybe even especially black women would
be pressured in some way to use
technologies to change the traits and
their children that's not you know I
talked about science fiction that's not
science fiction it can be done today and
we need to think about the morality and
politics of selecting out genes which
are considered to be socially unvalued
or socially harmful does that help to
answer your question it does but there's
a clear market interest in exactly that
kind of dystopic selection yes what
becomes of those who want to have not
only you know children but they're
perfect ideal of a child I mean I've
been thinking about these issues because
it's sort of you know what's in my brain
right now yeah in the talk and there are
a number of people I can imagine both
within the community and outside who
would imagine their perfect child having
certain lighter brighter whiter
characteristics here we can all find
that atrocious but they're the consumers
and anxiety one would imagine that they
have you know some level of a right to
pursue through you know their own means
what they like well that's not
necessarily true I mean we'll we can
and what what rights and tail and who's
who gets to have rights and who doesn't
all of that is invented there's no
natural right to have perfect children
there's and underlying that there's no
natural definition of what a perfect
child is so one of my biggest complaints
about the whole debate is that it
assumes that there is some universal
neutral natural definition of what a
perfect child is and even underlying
that there is an assumption that there
is some universal naturally natural
unbiased definition of what human
flourishing is because often ethicist
will say well this is to promote human
flourishing as if human flourishing is a
given what is human flourishing not only
that the people who can afford to these
technologies on the market to be able to
produce their perfect children tend to
be people who don't need social change
to be privileged and so the very idea
that we're going to rely on gene-editing
in order to produce human flourishing
embeds within it the concept that these
technologies can produce a society that
will benefit everyone when in fact the
people who are promoting it tend to be
people who already have the privileges
in society that are the most privileges
in society the people who would do
better by social change changing
structural inequalities rather than
relying on technologies to change genes
they don't have the same clout in these
debates
so if we really had a democratic debate
where there was representation of people
with disabilities representation of
people of color representation of poor
people people who are less advantaged
than most of the people engaging in this
bioethical debate they might have a very
they might disagree with what you just
said that you have a right if you've got
the money to afford it
to use these technologies I think that
there is an ethical that they we need to
have ethical and political I'm not
talking about just applying as you said
the principles that were created by a
group of bioethicists I think ethical
that includes justice as a big component
of ethics and if we had that real
participation there might be a decision
made that these technologies are harmful
to society as a whole and that we
shouldn't allow for gene editing for
Reproductive purposes why not I mean we
it's not the case that anything that can
be done should be done I hope that's not
our morality because there's a whole lot
of horrible things that can be done
right now with the push of a button
we're all afraid of my task right now
yes we don't want those to happen and we
hope that ethical principles that
include justice are a halt but a halt to
that
[Laughter]
and I'm not you know I'm not yelling at
you I'm yelling at the people that think
that this isn't that this is all assumed
and natural and that it shouldn't be the
subject of critical debate this is
really important stuff that could have a
huge impact on human wellbeing in the
world I mean this is a whole other
dimension that can affect human
wellbeing in the whole world yeah thank
you so much for sure talk this is I work
in Latin America and and I'm seeing a
lot of probably the the ideology and
that is more prominent there which is
not in the US where we had a Herrenvolk
democracy where I was like you know one
one job okay baby right America the idea
of ethnicity South Hangul is that
through racial mixture yet you arrive at
the ideal the perfect baby I'd rather
the conversation and so I'm seeing that
more and more of that in the u.s. ideas
yeah notion of racial mixture mixed-race
people as being the answers yeah social
inequalities yeah kind of a shift but
also relying on this biological
understanding of brave yeah and racial
reproduction so I'm wondering how do you
see that embrace of this new race
mixture solutions yeah an equality
figuring within this long DeRay of
racial reproduction yeah yeah well there
there's a couple ways in which racial
mixture is seen as ending racial
divisions within the United States as a
solution one is that racially mixed
people as sort of like what you were
describing that racially mixed people
can become the new face of America and
every so there will no there will no
longer be racial divisions
because everyone will be mixed that
that's one wave and you can see I've
seen lots of fashion articles in the New
York Times Style section where they show
that models are increasingly these
racially ambiguous people who I don't
know if it's because their scene is more
attractive or if it's because they
appeal to people of all different races
and you know you know you can sell your
products more easily but there there is
this this fantasy that America is going
to become so racially mixed that you
won't be able to tell racial divisions
anymore another is that when people
discover that they are actually mixtures
of different races that the especially
white people discover this life they
will discover this they won't be racist
anymore because I'll say oh my goodness
I'm ten percent Native American I am NOT
pure white so I must love Native
Americans now I can't roll you know so
um I well let me go back to a slide when
to just vote one answer to that way back
way back there okay the people who wrote
this preamble to this statute knew that
those children were racially mixed the
very children they were talking about
were racially mixed the question is what
should be the political implications of
racial mixture of having mixed-race
children in our colony and what what did
they do with those children they enslave
them they enslave them yes exactly if
the mother the mother was black they
enslaved the chil
yes yes exactly yes yes it was the
status of the mother if she were
enslaved black women the children were
enslaved but the but my point is that it
did not lead to some liberating view of
humanity now you say oh well we're so
far more advanced now than we were in
1662 but we despite all the advances
over the next what is that 400 years 400
years 400 years later we're still asking
this question about what's the
significance of racial mixture so if
over the 400 years it hasn't led all the
racial mixture that people have become
aware of hasn't led to this acceptance
of our common humanity why do we think
it's going to now in fact what are we
seeing that we're seeing a resurgence of
blatant explicit white nationalism at
the highest levels of government so I'm
just not very very confident that the
mere fact of knowledge about racial
mixture is going to lead to some
political change I think that we need a
combination of political organizing in
order to end the biological concept of
race and the racism that that concept is
designed to support as well as what I
was saying at the end of my lecture new
ways of thinking about our common
humanity that I don't think are going to
be produced just by the knowledge about
racial mixture it's going to take more
than that and we can't rely on it that's
not to say that there aren't
people who might become enlightened when
they think about the implications of
racial mixture for the biological
definition of race you know as I said
this question does have implications
about the very credibility of a notion
that raises biological so it might
enlighten pieces something of my look
and say oh wow that's right they did
create legally the definition of black
people no it was not it's not natural it
has to be written into law and into
social norms and customs and all of that
but we can't rely on it we can't rely on
it yes factor this quick question sure
we I love TV i watch TV what that's
right my day job and night job right
yeah but so many products are using
mixed-race couples yes to sell their
product you don't have nothing to do
with race yes but and precisely when we
have more anti black racism yeah that's
being voiced yeah in the marketplace of
ideas and yeah in the marketplace yeah
and as you said we have all kind of
bizarre things happening with our
federal government yeah and so how are
you thinking yeah I'm Mariana I talk
about all the time yeah I'm trying to
wrap my head around it and I don't have
an answer so I'm hoping yeah Wow you
know well I this is probably something
we would have to just discuss and muse
over because it does seem very
contradictory that mixed-race couples
are being used to sell products at a
time when the biological concept of
races in a revival white racial purity
concept reviving white Nationals being
revived dehumanization of black people
intensifying so I we probably would also
have to ask the advertisers there
they're probably the ones that know
what's behind this but
imagine that there is this this way of
trying to appeal to a broader audience
by having more diversity in in
advertising and as I said the very image
of the mixed-race a racially ambiguous
person is attractive to many consumers
apparently at least the Advocate I'm
assuming they've done some research to
back up this this new way of advertising
on the other hand I would also say
though that these ads are controversial
it's not as if when the other cheerios
ads it shows the right the the black was
a black mother and white father I think
I can't remember which way it went and
the little girl with the curly hair and
the light brown skin there was a big
social media backlash against that and
we still think it's contrasted to me
what's amazing is that it's
controversial its controversial like we
it warrants as a deep discussion about
it and there there were very vicious
attacks and this happens all the time
when these ads go up you know on Twitter
and Facebook and all the other social
media venues but cheers Cheerios stood
firm yes I believe it did although I I
don't I don't watch enough TV I've seen
the ads oh yeah and so you know on the
one hand we could say that some kind of
progress that it's allowed on TV but the
very fact that we think of it as
progress and that it's controversial to
me shows that we haven't become as far
as we might suspect from the fact that
those as exists it still
third weird weird to people that there
are families that have people of
different races that's considered weird
in the United States how strange the bat
should be in 2017 that's weird
no yeah I press robbers thank you so
much
sure sure I have another question about
about images yeah okay so we read your
we read clean my body this semester I'm
in my class and the question I ask the
students is why does professor Roberts
start with the trajectory of figures
right yeah different stereotypes and
it's not immediately clear right they
just serve a book on the racialized
regulation reproduction would be minor
so so now you're here so I yeah
what's the answer I mean so and so my
first thought was like it's just sort of
ideological cover for for you know the
politics I don't know and in that case
right it's a Cheerios ad sort of more
ideological cover or some other kind of
relationship between representation and
policy for you right okay so is the
question is why I started with all those
images because I think I I guess I
included them because which is different
for why I started with them but I
included them because I think that
they're very powerful in a way you know
in a really deep way you know not just
at the level of they represent
stereotypes about black women but that
they represent ways of thinking about
race and gender and class and we know
that they actually did have an influence
on the abolition of welfare rights in
the United States so they do have that
concrete impact but they also I think
represent a way of thinking that is
essential to understanding how these
power
these are able to exist there these are
policies that contradict all sorts of
principles that Americans are supposed
to live by so how can it be that for
example at the medical university in
South Carolina you could have a
collaboration of doctors and police
officers to arrest patients well that
violates every basic principle of
medical practice so how could the
doctors have done that how could it be
that you could have a maternity ward
which is usually described as you know
the sanctity of maternal miraculousness
that in what what is more sanctified
than the maternity room
what's pretty what's okso protected at
one point husbands couldn't even enter
it you know so so it's so glorious and
so godly where mirror the miracle of
birth takes place and women perform
their most important role on earth
giving birth to babies now that's a way
that the maternity ward is usually
described so how can it be that police
officers can burst in drag a mother just
giving birth in handcuffs and leg
shackles bleeding told to sit on a towel
because she's still bleeding from the
delivery and holler off to jail how can
that happen that you know we I could go
on and on with all the deep
contradictions that happen to black
women that violate every principle that
we're supposed to hold true in America
so to me to understand how that can
happen you have to understand how racism
and sexism can change can change the
entire
either people oh okay
they were being arrested because their
babies tested positive for drugs so what
happened was of the Medical University
of South Carolina entered into a
collaboration written you know written
document
agreement with police and prosecutors to
drug test their patients and arrest the
ones who tested positive for drugs or
arrest new mothers whose babies tested
positive for drugs and so they were
being arrested for a child abuse or for
distribution of drugs to a minor made up
cry made-up uses of criminal statutes in
extremely brutal ways now and anyone who
says well that's because of their drug
use during pregnancy can you imagine
that happening in a private hospital
when a middle-class white woman's baby
tests positive for drugs which does
happen test positive for opioid use for
example today they're not treated that
way their doctors don't turn them in
their doctors find them help for their
addiction and so how could it be that
the ethical principles that doctors
learn the very deep sanctity of the
maternity ward could be invaded in that
way it's because of a framework a way of
thinking that flips how they completely
flips the way that people think about
those principles when applied to black
women so where does that come from where
does that come from I think it comes
from it's you know stereotype it's just
too too thin a word to even describe
how deeply embedded these ideas of black
woman's threat dangerousness are and so
that's that's why I began with those
images because they help to explain how
all the policies I describe in the rest
of the book could even take place I'm
sure thank you thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]